well I don't support a total boycott I
think the president should definitely
boycott the opening ceremonies I think
that would send the strongest political
message I have mixed feelings about it I
would feel like that would not be the
best thing that's kind of like the pot
calling the kettle black the united
states actually boy cause it's 1980
olympics in moscow and that was really a
bad thing to do because the level of the
games would suffer wouldn't bother me
one bit they probably it'd be a good
idea i would feel sorry for the athlete
athlete's i think it would be a bad move
and it sends a signal i think they think
the big mistake was made on the part of
the olympic committee and giving china
these olympics in the first place
politically yes
politically yes I don't think it
necessarily would economically is I
think John's been benefiting a lot from
from our economic involvement you know
and that we could potentially benefit if
we had more cultural openness towards
some of the things that they do do well
you know you know socializing healthcare
could be a good thing they would not
give any any I think a sufficient
adjustment to the pure politics in in
Tibet or or everywhere else very little
of Haiti it's not a good idea to have
the Olympics in china it was not a good
idea when they first thought about
it's not a good idea now it won't be a
good idea 10 years from now politics and
sports should be separated I think it
would be bad for trade relations bad for
publicity it would humiliate the Chinese
that in a way they don't want to be
humiliated in
not at all i think that the boycotts
totally ridiculous should have been
lifted years ago I really actually don't
have much knowledge of that oh yeah I
was instrumental absolutely i think that
fidel castro step down because he got
like 90 years old and too sick to rule
the country oh no i don't think it had
any any effect whatsoever most boycotts
don't have any effect of course not no
people in the u.s. kind of smuggle the
seagulls if i'm not mistaken i mean to
because cuban cigars are the power the
best knows that